welcome back to New Rock starss I'm Eric
Voss and looki season 2 was filled with
countless design details that made every
shot of the series a full meal to Feast
upon the designers who work at
perception are one of the groups of
visual effects artists who work on
Marvel titles including many of the
opening and closing credits that you
know and love and specifically on Loki
uh if you watch new rock stars you know
the closing credits might be the most
fun part to pull apart to find cool
details and I am so honored to be here
with artists from perception I here with
Doug Appleton Chief creative and Greg
Herman creative supervisor from
perception who worked on Loki welcome
guys hello thanks for having us I'm I'm
so excited to hear that in real time
because I love watching these videos
so totally it's a treat pleasure to be
here thanks for having us Eric and this
video is sponsored by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform that makes launching
your own website a breeze well it's so
great to be here with you um your team
posted this really cool breakdown on the
perception website that just kind of
like went through some of the cool work
that you did um that opened my eyes
because you know when I go through these
there's there's so much imagery and you
don't know like how much of it was just
pulled from like stock imagery with with
you guys it sounds like you recreated a
Loki workspace or TVA workspace correct
uh for the closing credits yeah so uh
that's in Greg's basement uh we
recreated a TVA workspace because we had
done Loki season 1 was done during the
pandemic so like we couldn't go anywhere
toot or um and you know Greg is a wildly
wildly talented person so we had uh he
had built this all in his basement and
shot it all all himself uh in in North
Carolina and that was kind of the the
process so I'm sure if Greg could move a
camera you'd see just a bunch of loky
stuff next to you want do you want me to
bust it out I I was saving it I was
gonna all right yeah I was going to take
a quick sip of this 800 bcy old coffee
really quick oh my God holy crap that's
amazing did you have to did you get that
from Marvel Studios or did you make it
yourself like no just how do you get I
just bought I just got that on eBay and
then got a bunch of labels and we talked
to Kate and she was like could you make
the coffee be from 800 BC we were like
uh sure that's a strange request but you
got it so yeah there's all kinds of you
know we got this we got you know the
water cooler there's all kinds of little
like this is from Autumn aropa credit
the actual camera with the iso meters
and things like that I mean I've got
like a pretty decent amount of like
props and things that could be you know
oh my God you know just like lives in
his uh lives in his basement now and
like it's uh it's cool so you know a lot
of that stuff we're making on on our own
of course it's a talking to Marvel all
the time and you know we get to watch
the watch the shows and see kind of all
the set design and things but then it
becomes this constant communication of
you know what do you like do you like
this do you like that like this and like
Greg's saying that um you know never
seen so much from Greg right now he just
doing like a fashion show I know it's
great I'm just gonna narrate over it um
guys I got something here this might be
the one here this might be the one oh
what is it is it going to be uh there it
is oh wow the original l1130
fingerprints that's amazing that's so
cool that you get to keep it I made all
this stuff and it's just been in my
office I like printed it out and it's
sat here ever since we shot it so it's I
hope that it just stays here you know
we've shot a few of these things there's
uh sometimes we have to give the props
back Sometimes When We Make the props
ourselves uh we get to we get to keep
them and you must have a mindstone you
got to have an infinity stone paperwork
somewhere I got that I got that right
here is it plugged in it's recharging
yeah yeah plug in you mean this guy oh
wow these are like these are like little
like you because they're out of focus in
the sequence you don't really see that
how low low quality these are these are
like very low F like little they look
like little like gummy candies actually
yeah what does it is it fiberglass what
is that made out of it's like plastic
basically it's like rubber plastic yeah
it's plastic with an LED and with an LED
inside it blinks and things like that
you push on it and like out of focus on
a paper weight like in the foreground
you're like it's a it's an infinity
stone sure yeah and then we you know we
doctor it in post we you know we add a
little more glow a little more lens
flare to it make it more magical I love
that I mean this is um something I try
my best and I mean I I'm not a visual
effects artist I I don't really make
props outside of like some really crappy
papier-mâché stuff I used to make for my
sketch team so when I like see this
stuff show up in in movies and
television shows I really try to
illuminate that to viewers because I
think what makes Loki special and I
think a lot of viewers sense this they
just might not know the detail is that
it really is a collaborative effort so
much that Marvel is like a previs
concept art Vision brought to life
through animation which can be beautiful
sometimes as we saw with eil you know in
the in the final episode of the season
but in other ways you do have some
really talented artists like you guys
who are just putting their all into this
and it shows up on camera there's a
tactility to Loki that you don't always
see in Marvel titles and you can like
see the artist fingerprints on stuff
sometimes in you know Mac opic imagery
sometimes literally smudges and
fingerprints on things and that's what
brings it to life and I and I just Kudos
all the credit in the world goes to you
guys for like bringing this to life yeah
that one of the things we wanted to uh
we wanted to bring into this because you
know like you said you watch the show
like they're really shooting on these
gorgeous gorgeous sets and you know we
didn't want to have a a sequence and
obviously you know I say we Marvel us
you know Kate here and the directors and
everyone you know didn't want to have uh
this title sequence that didn't feel
like it was a part of the show right and
it if we did a a big CG kind of flyth
through of the world it wouldn't feel
like what the show is and I think it you
know it's a testament to them that
season one and season two feel so
cohesive that essentially the same title
sequence with little bit of updates in
it works for both seasons and that's
because I think we made it so tactile
you can hold everything you can feel all
of it and that really fits with what
they did yeah there's there's just a
weight to it that's really great and one
of the things I didn't realize and this
is something that I I saw in our video
analyses was this device of the Loom
clock this is on the loom observation
deck aka the loom room this I didn't
know if it was like an atomic clock but
at some point I see that and I'm like
616 and I lose my mind and then so we
try to find the the highest quality
version of the episode and I look at all
the other numbers and I'm like okay damn
it there's no there's no 838 there's no
uh there's no 1610 like okay so I got to
ask you guys you constructed this Loom
clock uh this was your idea like tell me
about this the Loom clock was in the
episode like that's a prop that Marvel
uh you know brilliantly crafted I love
that prop I think that prop is like it
caught my eye right away and I think
it's because of the design it's like a
bubble and it's not like a flat clock
you would see in the TVA it's like this
very specific strange bubble and I'm
like that design is just so cool and I'm
like H we need to recreate that in CG
and we because we did a clock we did a
CG clock for uh you know season one with
all the like different hands and you
know you called out like one of them was
green and was going backwards and I'm
like ah you nailed it dude okay but but
but then um but then you know we wanted
to reprise that idea for season two and
we were like oh we can't just make
another clock let's make this cool ass
like multi-dimensional clock that you
know you know I can I can also give away
a another little Easter egg turns out
what we decided to do was the artwork
from the clock made its way to being on
the record player and on the record
album artwork nice so like if you look
at the album artwork and what's on the
actual record playing you'll realize
that it's
actually referencing the clock the the
multiversal clock and um we thought that
that was really cool because it
deteriorates as the episode deteriorates
and then of course you know uh episode
six it's like everything's back to
normal yeah that was Co yeah yeah people
had time to watch it um but yeah spoiler
for everything as of Loki season 2
finale yeah I'm looking at the record
player here you have all the same
numbers the same kind of color coding
that's really really cool so do you
think that's like an indicator of what
the hell this Loom clock is measuring is
it like a measurement of like time
cyclical nature a measurement of
stability of the Loom yeah I think so
it's something that you know as much as
I would love to be like we're in there
every day and we know all the secrets of
like the stuff we're working with like
at some point like here's a cool clock
let's use that but I think our you know
our interpretation of it is that like
putting that back on the record player I
think you're right like it it represents
sort of the cyclical nature how they're
kind of going around around especially
you know at the end like Loki's
revisiting moments that are in the show
and you kind of get that repeating
nature that you'd see on a record player
on a clock and try to tie all those
things together we had a um you know
there was like a a record that was blank
that needed artwork and we needed album
artwork so we're like what is it going
to be and I was like well it's like a
clock I mean we're working in like
cyclical like spinning patterns it's a
no-brainer to make it a clock so we had
slugged in some initial like kind of
Grandfather Clock old school like clock
kind of imagery to be like yeah it's a
clock it's time we're dealing with time
and then through the process it just
evolved that we were like it would be
really cool if it was the multiversal
clock that we designed in CG so we were
like let's make that the album artwork
so that's how it happened I love that
there's like all kinds of little details
that are in the closing credits of
things that you know we see from season
2 episode one but don't pay off until
episode 5 of the Season like the Zartan
contingent book yeah is that something
Marvel provided you did you have to
recreate that book no no no that's a
Marvel thing but but you know we were
like apprehensive to put it in because
we were like is this you know there's
that fine line between like are we
creating uh like potential stir online
that could lead to a spoiler in some way
or is this such a subtle detail that
it'll pay off in a perfect way for
audiences so we're just trying to always
walk that line of like well we don't
necessarily want to give it away but we
also would love to set up a reveal or
set up a payoff and I feel like that
zarten contingent is a total payoff
because when you you see it and you're
like yeah it's on Keys card and you're
like what the hell is that I don't know
but then when you get to it you're like
oh that now it makes sense you know
we've been watching this all along and
with zero context so sometimes it feels
good to have those payoffs and one of
the things that we we constantly talk
about here is we want our title
sequences to wear in not wear out and I
think that idea is that you can watch
the Zartan contingent and see the whole
episode the whole season and it's not
until you get to the end and you revisit
that title sequence again that you're
like oh that's been in there the whole
time that's been there now you're
picking out things that on First Watch
meant nothing but episode two there's a
few scenes that mean a little more and
episode three there's a few scenes that
mean a little more and you know we're
very well aware that people skip title
sequences as much as it breaks my heart
uh I'm very well aware that that happens
so what we try and do is put stuff in
there that evolves and change whether we
are literally changing it throughout the
episodes which we do and in Loki with
adding new things every every episode or
if it just changes kind of narratively
narratively because now you have more
information this idea of that the
sequence wears in it becomes something
that you wanna you want to watch not
something that you're like ah I'm done
with that oh yeah agreed I I hope that
at least like people who are on YouTube
following this stuff know not to ever
skip through the credits especially with
Marvel because you never know when a
random post credit scene is going to pop
up what drives me crazy I we're tangent
in here but like drives me crazy how
streaming platforms will after like the
work you guys have done and we've just
gone into the standard blackfield white
text um they will minimize it and be
like next episode I'm like no no no I
want to see I want to see every artist I
want to see every uh musician who worked
on this everybody in business legal
Affairs at Disney corporate like I want
to see everyone because for my job like
I wna like sometimes it'll be like
additional voices by and like you'll
hear like oh Sam whitward did a voice on
this episode what does that mean
interesting yeah it's something that
that I think I thought that my mom kind
of instilled in me every time we go to a
movie we would sit through all the
credits long before I was doing this
stuff and my mom was like well that's
someone else's son or daughter who
worked on this movie and we should see
the names and like so I always stay
through the CR before doing any of this
and then as I was get wanted to like get
into this industry staying through the
credits was like oh what company worked
on this but who was that what they do
what they do what they do and I'm like
all right now I got a list of places I
can work for so like you know I I Lov
for you it's it's Easter egg stuff but
you know for me it's like who are the
the people in the studios and the and
the work but everyone should stay
through credits that's a long tangent
butay CR cred I think that's that's
great parenting and if if for no other
reason than to give yourself like just a
few minutes to think about the movie and
the experience you just had like I think
that's really the thing like you it's
kind of like after a workout and you
just need like kind of a moment in the
sauna just to kind of chill out you know
perfect met for it too the other thing
like I do the same thing with my kids
and I make them sit through the credits
but we get a little bit more like we go
I I show them I go look guys this whole
first batch is production that means
it's everybody that worked on the
shooting of the movie and then they'll
they'll go okay it's production done I'm
like yep visual effects is starting I'm
like this is the people that got to work
on the movie after it was shot this is
all the people that do on the computer
all that magic and then and then they go
where's your stuff and I go oh it's at
the very very end
tiny little thing right there tiny
little moment get comfortable yeah get
comfortable exactly that's cool though
yeah I'm with you guys I do the same
thing with my kids and and and now they
have come to respect it okay end of the
tangent we can move on yes big holiday
feast aren't just about what's on the
table they're about the whole experience
the company the decorations the vibe for
lack of a better word running an online
business is similar offering a quality
product isn't enough you want to make
sure things are just right and for that
there's Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com neww rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain I want to ask about okay so we
talked about how the Loom clock I love
this detail that it was cracked and then
episode 6 it's fixed again and another
thing that you pointed out was how after
episode 4 the the Rhythm in the speed of
the closing credits reflects the ending
of episode four which ends with Victor
timely getting spaghettified and that
you guys intentionally did that to just
give the viewer what we're just talking
about like a moment to kind of like
think about and reflect upon what
happened but I want to know from you
guys how much did you know about what
was coming from episode five from
episode six before you made that
decision we saw the whole we saw all the
episodes uh in advance and that's where
we were able to understand that we could
actually deconstruct the title sequence
Itself by episode five so that's where
that came from was just marvel being
transparent and saying hey get your eyes
on this stuff and watch these episodes
so you can contribute creatively
appropriate material and appropriate
creative that fits the show one of the
great things about season 2 since we had
done season one and you know before
season one started we didn't know what
the idea was for the title sequence
right and then we we all come to this
idea we have this great title sequence
going into season two they shot things
specifically for the title sequence they
were on these incredible sets and they'd
know oh let's get a closeup of this like
those are tan contingent let's get a
closeup of this thing because that'll be
great to put in the title sequence but
get a closeup of that and so you know it
made our lives a lot easier to now have
stuff that was shot specifically for the
title sequence um like it was always a
part of it from the beginning that you
know Season Two this title sequence
would be what it was and so the the
short answer is yes we got to know what
was going to happen beforehand before we
started making the thing um which
absolutely helps to know we can plant a
seed in episode one that'll pay off in
episode six and it's just it's really
helpful to have that because we want we
don't want to make a title sequence that
only works for episode episode one and
then you get to episode two and you're
like wait that's not the show that this
is right so we kind of want to see
everything so we can try and make
something that fits for the whole whole
sequence yeah we're very inspired by
like The Simpsons because that title
sequence changes and we love the idea
that like the couch is always this
updated thing and so I think we're like
maybe taking and pulling some
inspiration from that concept that you
know maybe we could inject our own you
know version of that into some of the
Marvel work that we're doing and keep
people like Doug saying it's like we're
trying to make you kind of break into
the title not push away from it but kind
of realize that there's layers flavored
and layered to kind of keep you coming
back so ultimately that's the hope and
the dream that idea started in uh when
we had done W division um every episode
as you know is a very different feel
like episode one is you know black and
white and then you get to like 90s and
2000 so like every episode feels so
different
and we needed a way into our sequence
which doesn't feel anything like the
rest of the show um and we had done that
by that first few shots being clips from
the show we just watched like well we
got to change this every episode now
right because every episode and that
kind of started this snowball of like
now every time we do one of these we
like oh what can we change this time
what can we change for Loki what can we
change for w division or any other
sequences so if you go back to any of
the ones we've done that's always and I
think it's just become a thing with
Marvel now that they like to do with the
TV showes is that every the sequence is
always different a little bit in some
way okay I between Loki and W division
specifically W division like in January
February 2021 just the way those
episodes ended like anytime I think back
on it I get shivers down my spine just
the like the creepy roseberry's baby
music and the visuals the digital stuff
turning into like flowers and crap like
guys that that was like such a huge part
of my life for like two two months and
like maybe it's just AG coming back I
loved it it was it's one of my favorites
that we've done and I think that is not
just in the content that we we made for
it not just in the visuals but just the
whole process that was the first title
sequence we had done from start to
finish during the pandemic remotely at
home you know and that early pandemic we
are we're pitching this thing we're
doing production on it um you know I
really like the idea behind that and
it's something that we've bring to Loki
as well that the sequence itself is The
Narrative of the show if you go back and
watch the sequence we are outside the
world watching TV we move into this
pixel world that is now Wanda has
created her world out of pixels we're
seeing the family life that she's
created we're seeing it all fall apart
and crumble and we're ending at just the
two wedding rings which is what the
whole thing's been about the whole time
is her Envision and so when you go back
and watch that that's The Narrative of
the show right that is we don't know
what's going on in the first few
episodes now we're in this TV world and
it's all falling apart it's the same
thing with Loki that you know you kind
of you're watching it you don't really
know what's happening and then as the
sequences progress they're getting
deteriorated like the TVA is getting
deteriorated by episode five our whole
sequence is falling apart and like the
letters are moving out of order and you
know the lines are kind of
Bend yeah falling into that order like
things are deteriorating and then
episode 6 it's all you know perfect and
fixed again and so we're trying to bring
some narrative that if you like in you
know it's in an abstract way it's not
giving away the show but you know as you
go back and watch like oh wait that is
that's the structure of the show that's
what it did one of the really helpful
things you guys did was design these
like labels for whether we were on the
sacred timeline or the branched timeline
because often I think you guys might
know this you'll watch a Marvel show and
there's just like clearly not great
communication and there'll just be some
random like title text on screen and
it's like wait that doesn't fit with the
timeline or that doesn't make logical
sense this is like one show where I
could just I felt like I was in good
hands I was like okay yes someone is
helping us but you guys added every time
it was branched different places on the
like or different parts of it that were
branching off how did you make those
decisions like was there any anything
you were trying to communicate with that
it started like oh wouldn't it be cool
if we actually put branches and and had
branches on the graphic itself that
actually start to change and grow and
evolve through the course of the
narrative and that would just fit with
the way that the loom is like slowly you
know overloaded more and more so I felt
like that was the start of it and then
once you know our awesome uh showrunner
Kevin Wright he's such a cool dude and
he's like he was so on board with like
all of our wacky ideas and that's what
made it so cool was that like we would
be like he's something a little more
like controversial and outlandish but
could be cool and he's like I love that
idea that's that's awesome and we're
like yes so yeah I think a lot of it has
to do with Marvel being cool enough to
like be open to some of these wacky
ideas that we have where yeah it could
could just be straightforward it could
be streamlined but it's way cooler if
you have like Branch timelines that are
different every time and like every time
you see one of the branch timelines it
is it is specifically different like we
went out of our way to make sure that
they we're not just repeating the same
configuration of branches but it's
always a new configuration of branches
yeah and I I think in just a very
practical sense it's a quick way to tell
people you're on a branch timeline or
you're on the sacred timeline and that's
also you know where it starts from too
because there's so much jumping back and
forth that we needed a quick easy read
and it kind of became this like here's a
weird idea oh it also happens to be a
quick read even if you can't even read
anything you see a graphic of a branch
timeline or a straight timeline like oh
I know I know where those are it's got
to have multiple layers to it it can't
just be cool it also has to have a
reason for why it looks like that yeah I
mean the you know a lot of our audience
it's like we have to try to make things
as iconic as possible so that the quick
read can just be visual a lot of times
so I feel like what you're saying Doug
is is absolutely a great point it's like
this idea that we need to like be able
to flash something on screen and assume
that like 70% of the people are not
gonna get it or see it or read it but
but there's probably most people will
and if we have something visually to
kind of like back that up then it's just
that much more of a handhold or or or a
shove in the right direction to kind of
get them like oh okay it's a branch got
it we saw the branches branches got it
so it's like these little things that
that do a lot of the heavy lifting
visually um but that's yeah at some
point it's less important that it's 1983
and it's more important that it's a
branch timeline yo for sure for sure but
um the fact that it is still like the
early 80s versus the late 70s versus the
1890s I do like that you provided that
diversity of each different branch so
that it lets the viewers know that we
are literally on a different branch like
it's not just like the same branch that
we were on in the 80s this is like a
whole different kind of universeal
reality that we're in and the other
thing we added to it is as well uh which
I don't know if most people picked up on
but when we go into the future the
Branch goes to the right and we go to
the past the animation moves to the left
so you kind of you also get that
movement left to right that you're like
oh I get it I know which one is that's
really cool I now I have to go back and
watch that I did not catch that that's
so cool so like in the future like uh
the like the like lus like lenus oh
something that Beyond us yeah something
yeah something Beyond now it goes so it
wasn't so much we didn't want to T the
show in like a future time of the show
because the future time of the show is
gonna be like I know if you watch this
in 10 years like that's still now the
past so it's anything that's like far
beyond in the in the future it kind of
it goes one way or the other depending
on if we're jumping forward or
backwards I like you're gonna have some
people in 2080 who are like wait a
minute this no long
for um Eric I'm so sorry I I need to hop
out of here um okay but I'm I can I can
stay on thanks so much Doug and thanks
for making time for us it was amazing
talking to you yeah am talking to you
too all right I'll talk to you later
okay I just have two more things I want
to ask you about you also worked on the
star map in the Marvels and there was
different like planetary names and we
started to see a couple of them in the
breakdown uh that we did of that movie
where like each initial was someone's
name and then the number was someone's
birthday right true of your team of the
perception team yeah you nailed it so we
saw Veronica Gil your name is in there
there's like a GH something that's so
that's I'm I'm GH 528 that's uh my
initials in birth date uh you might see
a PF 919 in there which is uh one of our
artists Pedro Fleming who worked on it
um you know uh I believe there might be
uh an ed for Eric Daly our head of
production there's probably uh a JL or
uh I believe maybe a DG um which would
be uh Jeremy lasier or Danny Gonzalez
are owners the owners of perception so
my favorite one one of those is in 2014
Captain America Winter Soldier there is
that Hydra sequence that reveals that
reveals so I I edited that and and and
designed that and got to got to do that
sequence uh and there is a ton of Easter
eggs in that one and there's a there's a
a shot that you'll see arnam Zola um
mixed in with a bunch of Project
Paperclip scientists uhhuh yeah yeah
yeah well you know the Russo Brothers
just love D that clip but we couldn't
get the rights to it we couldn't license
it so we were like yeah sorry we can't
use this clip production was like why
don't you guys just be all the faces on
the on the Project Paperclip scientists
so we became like you can see like all
of our eyes nose and mouth gets cut out
and put on the Project Paperclip
scientists
amongst so yeah if you see that like
kind of like shining push in where we
like bump into like arnam Zola and
2014's Winter Soldier you will you pause
that shot you'll see dog you'll see me
actually I'm in there twice I'm on two
different heads but it's like oh my God
our whole office got in that shot
everyone in our office is is actually a
member of project paper clip our art
director Christian haberern who has been
with us the whole time um also worked on
Winter
Soldier I put his name as the author of
the article that wrote so so he's the
one that wrote the article about you
know Howard Stark and somewhere in
Marvel Weeki somehow Christian haberern
is a Marvel Weeki character who is a
writer he's got a page he's got a page
as the writer of the of the newspaper
article so I'm perpetuating that idea
and I'm continuing to put Christian
havar in all of my newspaper uh
clippings for every other title sequence
that I've ever done
at some point there's going to be like a
plot line where there's a reporter who
is like gunning for Peter Parker's job
or something like that or he's like I
need new art for this it's like
Christian stop being so demanding you
exactly Daily Bugle reporter that's so
cool I love seeing this kind of stuff
and I love like you know the famously U
Ernest Klein and ready player one kind
of points out the history of like the
very first Easter egg in a video game is
just like an artist uh or a video game
developer who was like pissed that the
owners of the company didn't like credit
him so like I think that's kind of like
my favorite kind of Easter egg I've seen
like the artists be like hey hey we
worked on this too and putting their
little like stamps on stuff to like
become part of the world because and I
don't think obviously Kevin Wright the
studios are all for this kind of thing I
think what's funny is is that like
there's a
community um of the people that are
working on all this stuff and just
pouring our hearts and souls into it but
we watch what you do and we go hell yeah
dude that is insane like you're you're
we're putting all this stuff down like
like when you did your breakdown for uh
episode one um I was so impressed
because you I put in all this stuff that
I thought no one would ever know about
like I put in all this stuff about like
I wrote All I wrote all of these and I
like I like was like oh dude no one's
ever gonna know no one's ever gonna see
this stuff like I put in short Anders
cat I put in like all kinds of stuff
like of I I put in Nicola Tesla Vortex
math and and and specifically in Vortex
math nine is the god number in Vortex
math so I put all this and this is just
stuff that I'm personally into but I
feel like it relates to the TVA so it's
like yeah it makes sense and it's really
cool and it's like the the Marvel MCU
has touched on this stuff plenty of
times so I was like it's appropriate to
put you know these Quantum physicists
and these ideas of quantum mechanics
into this thing so yeah you but what I
was my point is is that like I'm sitting
here watching you and I'm like I can't
believe this guy like figured it all out
I was blown away man when I first watch
I don't know if I figured it all out I
appreciate that figured out way more
than I I was just like wow so I just saw
this stuff and I was like someone built
this someone printed this out and wrote
it it's so cool Greg to meet the person
who did I feel like some I've I've had
some closure now this has been
incredible that's awesome man I'm so
happy to actually have a chat chance to
chat with you about this because I put
your your breakdown on my website and I
was like you know so like I felt so
grateful that that that uh you went and
did the Deep dive and and found all
those nuggets of little Easter eggs that
I put in and it was so gratifying to
know but also a little terrifying
because I was like oh my God like
someone actually picked up on every
little detail that I thought no one
would ever care about and see so ever
since that Loki breakdown has come out
from season one I've been like hyper
aware uh and I think that's now like why
we're often saying like ah I wonder if
Eric will wonder if Eric boss will will
find this little negative of information
so that's why you you often come up
these days as of late so yeah I I won't
always find it but I will always be
looking I'll promise that I always keep
my eye of sour on on everything that I
can you're doing a good job of it man
it's working well um thank you so much
to these compliments and thank you for
all the work that you guys are doing
because this is like it means so much to
the viewership to the fan base just to
see artists working so hard to put in
all these little details and it it
really elevates the viewing experience
and it and it means a lot to us so thank
you and and great work keep up the great
work on everything that you do oh
appreciate it yeah it's our pleasure and
I know we we do it we do it for the fans
and we do it for you guys we do it for
everybody that that cares and that takes
the time to look through the stuff and
actually appreciate it it that's what
means the world and what what makes it
all worthwhile so and thanks for thanks
for chatting today it's been great to
finally meet you and chat about this and
about the Loki stuff Greg I'll let you
get back to your day this has been
incredible thank you so much um to both
of you guys uh this is a wonderful chat
and uh to everyone check out the great
work of perception they they go into
even more details on their website of
stuff that they' made uh and yeah I'll
be going back to look at a lot of stuff
that you guys have worked on this has
been an amazing chat thank you to
everyone for watching this video be sure
to subscribe to the full new rockstars
network channels and we'll see everyone
next time have a happy holidays
everybody and thanks Greg thanks man
later guys
[Music]
[Applause]
h